thank you to skillshare for supporting
this episode of journey to the micro
cosmos
if you are one of the first thousand
people to click the link in the
description
you can get a two month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
[Music]
the word that comes to our minds when
bacteria take the stage
is chaos each individual may be so small
as to feel insignificant but the
combined
presence of all of those tiny shapes
and so many different states of
excitement can be difficult to make
sense of
in fact in the 18th century carl von
linha
grouped the microbes he observed
together and named them
chaos the label didn't last in part
because it wasn't exactly specific but
the feeling endures
even when the movement seems more
ordered it's baffling to watch
like these little wiggles that seem so
snake-like
except for the unsettling vibration
that's added on or
you might see a mass of bacteria
collectively spinning in place
like a very odd microscopic flash mob
or you could throw them all together on
the same slide and end up with what
looks like
several different dance parties at once
but while the movements
may be a bit much to take in when
witnessed all at once
the source of that movement is almost
always the product of the same
masterpiece of bacterial ingenuity
the bacterial flagella we have been
wanting to talk about bacterial flagella
for a while but it's been tough because
well they're just
small and they're difficult to make out
in our footage fortunately
with a lot of patience and magnification
we have finally been able to spot them
for the first time in our micro cosmos
journey
but we have to zoom in a bit more on
this clip and you will need to ignore
the rounder protists buzzing around
instead focus on the rod shaped bacteria
and you will see these faint lines
coming off of them
those are the flagella more specifically
each strand you see is a filament which
is anchored to a joint
called the hook which then connects to a
motor
enclosed in the bacteria itself
words like hook and motor imply
something made from human hands with
metal bits of machinery and fuel
but biology builds with its own
materials
and the flagella is a complex assembly
made out of proteins that move like
gears
and it does function very much like one
of our motors
with a stator and a rotor and gears that
connect between them
but of course both arose independently
because if you want something to rotate
there is a best way to do it and both
nature
and humans in this case came up with the
same solution
though of course for bacteria the
movement of the motor is powered by
an electrochemical potential created by
pumping ions across the cell membrane
instead of by an internal combustion
engine
now if you've been on this journey with
us for a while you might be wondering
why are you talking about flagella like
it's a new thing
we've talked about tons of flagellates
before and even explained how they move
but there is a difference here those
flagellates
are eukaryotes and while the name is the
same
the actual appendage is definitely not
the bacterial flagella is a hollow tube
that sticks
out of the cell and rotates as dictated
by its motor it actually spins around
the eukaryotic flagella is a bundle of
microtubules
surrounded by cell membrane and it does
not rotate
it just flips back and forth to whip
around to move the cell and
unlike the ion gradients used to power
bacterial flagella eukaryotes rely on
the energy storing molecule
atp to fuel theirs so why do these
two very different assemblies have the
same name
well probably simply because when we
were originally looking at them
we didn't know any of this understanding
the biochemistry of these
marvelous machines has been a very long
involved careful process involving
thousands of scientists over decades
one of the original tests to see how
different bacterial flagella were from
eukaryotic flagella actually involved
basically taping the bacterial flagella
down and they found that when they did
that
instead of flopping back and forth the
bacteria themselves
spun around and around the movement of
bacteria
stood out to early observers for the
same reason it stands out to us
because it is so weird there's a mix of
sporadic movements and
directed movements but even with the
significant lack of grace there is
something coordinated
underlying this movement it comes down
to what
direction the bacteria's flagella are
rotating
when the motor turns the flagella
clockwise
the filaments form a coil that bundles
together
and that drives the bacteria straight
but when the flagella is turned
counterclockwise
the bundle comes undone and each
individual flagella
moves on its own and that creates
disarray
causing the bacteria to tumble randomly
around the microcosmos
in our world stumbling around randomly
might
seem like a bit of a liability but for
bacteria
this is an evolutionarily planned affair
helping the bacteria find food and light
tumbling around lets the bacteria sample
the world around them
looking for chemical scents or hints of
light that might
point them towards the resources they
need to survive
and when they catch those signals
whether it's a ray of light
or a chemical gradient the flagella turn
clockwise
to set the bacteria on a straight course
towards their next home
so while at first glance it seems messy
and
even a little broken the bacterial
flagella
it turns out is one of the most
majestic useful and powerful
structures in biology barely visible
but in our opinion completely deserving
of a fan club
all its own
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the
unseen world that surrounds us
if you're feeling like a chaotic
bacteria tumbling randomly through your
day-to-day life
skillshare can help you with classes
like planning a life you love
creating organizing and utilizing an
agenda
in this class host kelani lin will help
you create a planner using any notebook
or journal
in order to help you organize your daily
to-do's
refine your long-term goals and design a
unique
efficient planning system that works for
you
in order to create a life you love
skillshare is an
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning
with so much to explore real world
projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
and it makes it easy with short classes
that will fit into your daily routine
a premium membership will give you
unlimited access so you can join classes
and communities that are right for you
and an annual subscription to skillshare
is less than ten dollars a month and if
you're one of the first thousand people
to click the link in the description
you can get a two-month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership
thank you of course and always to all of
the people whose names are on the screen
right now
if you like what we do here and you'd
like to join them you can check out
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes
james weiss check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you